qu'elle vous nous parlez maintenant
devenir une ex du caire qui a connu un
succès absolument phénoménale à las
vegas son spectacle est là ça fait quand
même trois ans qu'elle dépose venu se
produire au québec et elle nous présente
son tout nouveau spectacle ici elle l'a
présenté hier à montréal et ça en a
surpris plus d'un parce qu'on
s'attendait le spectacle celui de las
vegas transportés ici un peu adapté pour
le public francophone pas du tout elle
avait vraiment mis toute la gomme pour
mettre du nouveau matériel et ça séduit
quelqu'un ma collègue tenir un point qui
nous qui vous a préparé ce qui suit moi
je vous dit bonsoir et merci merci
d'adèle à lady gaga en passant par
vanessa paradis et isabelle boulay
véronic dicaire possèdent toutes leurs
voix dans la sienne
et
là
mais
on n'avait pas vu un spectacle ici
depuis 2009 on la retrouve au sommet de
son art avec plus de 50 imitations
riche de son expérience à las vegas elle
revient avec une production conçue sur
mesure pour le public francophone qui
voulait pas non plus que les gens qui se
sont déplacés pour venir voir le
spectacle à las vegas et le même
spectacle j'avais envie aussi de faire
les nouvelles chanteuses comme valérie
carpentier puis brigitte boisjoli
chanson c'est tellement agréable
d'éviter ces jeunes filles de son retour
au québec lui permet de repousser ses
limites en se faisant de plus en plus
humoriste et là présentement au québec
est agréable parce qu'enfin on peut
faire ce que la veuve boulud foire et
plusieurs années les textes de josée
fortier les éclairages divo coin les
danseuses de las vegas tous contribuent
à faire de ce spectacle de deux heures
c'est un divertissement de grande
qualité
parmi les moments forts l'hommage aux
disparus
le clae gens on n'oublie pas ses grandes
chanteuses même chose pour edith piaf
après une trentaine de spectacles ici
véronic dicaire retournera à las vegas
il est déjà question d'une tournée
mondiale qui l'amènera en 2015 en
australie en europe et en asie une chose
à voir
mais le spectacle qu'on présente à las
vegas tout le côté international et tina
turner les bornes de houston et
s'exporte à véronic dicaire est épatante
est beaucoup plus qu un juke box humain
c'est tout le palmarès féminin des tous
premiers à la pointe radio canada
montréal